Do oncologists really believe that their care has to start immediately?
Well, that's kind of a loaded question.
I think the truth is, is that different oncologists believe different things.
And it's hard to make a growth and have a growth answer to that because everybody's different.
I do believe there's a lot of oncologists that really think that you need to start their care
immediately and your chance of recovery and overcoming your illness increases the faster that you can,
the earlier that you can diagnose a cancer and the faster you can start care.
But I do believe that the reason why they believe that is because they've been brainwashed
by the pharmaceutical industry. There's not a lot of evidence that supports that.
Now, I would agree with starting care earlier if you have certain types of cancer.
So if you have a cancer that's growing quite rapidly, then starting a more invasive care protocol
if you is probably in that patient's best interest.
If you're going to start chemotherapy, if you've made the decision to do chemotherapy
or radiation therapy or surgery, and then you're just putting it off because of other reasons,
that might not be a good idea at all because you're still, if you're going to go through it, you
want to go through it in the healthiest state you possibly can. However, cancers become a huge
economic bust for ecologists. It's only oncologists that make money off their prescriptions.
All doctors make money off vaccinations, but oncologists make money off of their prescriptions.
So if they prescribe chemotherapy, their income goes up.
Also, the cancer industry is really a financial industry.
If I was an oncologist at the University of Minnesota, and I was telling people to do herbs and to
hold off on their chemotherapy, I would be fired and be written up in front of the board,
probably see, have my license suspended at the very least. So they are under a lot of pressure.
I've had doctors tell me that they're in the golden handcuffs. They can't get out of it.
They don't make their own decisions. They are controlled by the hospitals and the big oncology
clinics. So if I worked for Minnesota oncology, guess what? It's run by
besters, educated hospital, hospital PhDs and such that art medical doctors at all,
they're just trained how to make the most money for their industry.
Interesting on this. No, I had a patient. This was about 10-12 years ago. She had metastatic cancer.
I can't remember where what her original cancer was. It was the top of my head.
But she had metastasis and she was in the hospital and she called me.
I gave her my cell phone because she was going through a lot of struggles. She called me and said
I'm in the hospital right now and I am so bad. She was wide. The radiologist, oncologist,
was just in here. He said, if I don't start radiation immediately, I'll be dead in two weeks.
But I said, what? It just makes me so bad. How can they say that? How can they say that?
I understand this woman was very much against doing any radiation. She was so upset.
And I talked her through it and we just tried to reason together. I always do. It's like you know
that you're under a lot of pressure, but it doesn't necessarily mean that their recommendation is
bad. Just because we maybe disagree with their bedside better, we disagree with their high pressure
tactics, doesn't necessarily mean that their recommendation is wrong. Well, all came down to she was
having difficulty walking. She had metastasis to the spine. She could, you know, she was, she had
pain. That was so bad. She finally agreed to the radiation. So she called the nurse and she said,
okay, I want to talk to the radiation oncologist. He came in and again, said, if we don't start
the radiation immediately, you're going to be dead in two weeks. So she said, okay, I
talked to the other doctor. I agreed. I'm willing to start the radiation. He said, great,
I'm going to have the nurse come in and get your schedule comes in and get your schedule. This
the first opening they had was in three weeks. So they scheduled her in three weeks. She called me back.
I have never heard somebody so absolutely limited on the phone. And rightfully so,
I'm going to be dead in two weeks. If I don't start radiation immediately, they said the oncologist,
I finally agreed to it. And their first opening is in three weeks. And he's okay with that.
That doesn't even make any sense. Well, this is the nonsensical high pressure tactics that they use.
That effect when I was looking for some pictures for this post. There's seminars out there for oncologists
to learn how to get people to agree with their care. I mean, I remember years ago,
carpractors were just lab-blasted for using high pressure techniques. And it was just horrible
on what they were doing. They couldn't even hold a candle to what oncologists do today.
Horrible high pressure techniques. And maybe it's because they're pressured by the the orders of
the oncology clinics, the oncology centers, the hospitals. I don't know. But it's awful. And
by what are the main things that we have always said is you always have more time than they lead on.
Always make sure that you take everything to prayer, that you slow down. There's always a
benefit talking to multiple people and getting second opinions. I can't tell you how many
people my old sister was told that if she didn't do chemotherapy, she was going to be dead.
In that many words by somebody at Minnesota oncology, she went down to Mayo for a second opinion.
And they said, well, we would even do chemotherapy in your case. And they offered her immunotherapy,
which she did one session. She didn't do well on it, but I do think it really helped her.
She's still alive today doing natural methods. I just think that it's just sad. It's just,
it's just downright sad. So yes, I do think there's some oncologists that are brainwashed in
the thinking that they had because they don't start care immediately. But I also think that they
don't think any other care is viable. I think they think that they're maybe a little bit higher
than God on the scale of knowledge. And nobody else knows a thing. It just is what it is. So I think there's
a little bit of multitude of counselors. Nothing wrong with getting their opinion. There's nothing
wrong with starting their care. But don't do anything based upon pressure. It certainly don't make
decisions based upon fear.